herzlich willkommen
die großen probleme der menschheit wie
klimawandel migration oder armut die
können wir menschen nur gemeinsam lösen
wer aber macht den anfang und wie
bringen wir die menschen dazu an einem
strick zu ziehen
jemand der weiß wie man die kooperative
seite des menschen zum vorschein bringt
ist ernst er forscht an der universität
zürich und gilt als weltweit führende
kunden herzlich willkommen
herzlichen dank dass ich hier sein darf
ja sie arbeiten ja als verhaltensökonom
empirisch machen viele experimente und
wir möchten auch mit einem experiment
anfangen geld habe ich mitgebracht das
spiel heißt vertrauens spiel darf ich
sie bitten das kurz zu erläutern
gut also dass vertrauen spiel das bildet
eine situation habe in der eine partei
einer anderen partei vertrauen kann aber
auch dass die andere partei das
vertrauen missbrauchen kann es beginnt
damit dass sie 10 franken haben nichts
in franken haben dass es hier noch
weitere 20 franken gibt und die idee des
spiels besteht darin dass man eine art
gläubiger schuldner beziehung abbildet
und der gläubiger der ist in der lage
dem schuldner einen geldbetrag zu geben
das wären in dem fall 10 franken oder
nichts ich kann in der 10 franken oder
nichts geben
und wenn ich ihnen diese zehn franken
gebe dann haben sie zunächst 20 franken
aber wie das häufig der fall ist wenn
seine gläubiger schuldner beziehung gibt
der der schulden an will ja das geld zum
beispiel wenn sie ein unternehmer ist
deshalb haben weil eine bessere
verwendung hat wir das geld als ich habe
und deshalb keiner das geld produktiv
einsetzen und durch diesen produktiven
einsatz des geldes vermehrt sich das
geld und es werden aus den zehn franken
die ihnen hinüber gesendet habe 30
franken wirklich eher symbolisch
verdreifacht heißt wird symbolisch
verdreifacht und jetzt bin ich am zug
und jetzt sind sie am zug
jetzt haben sie die möglichkeit mir das
beliebig viel oder gar nichts zurück zu
geben und sie können mich also sozusagen
im regen stehen lassen und mir gar
nichts zurückgeben dann haben sie jetzt
40 und ich hab nichts sie können mein
vertrauen honorieren indem sie mir einen
fairen anteil des gesamterlöses
sozusagen zurückgeben indem wir beide
zum beispiel mit 20 franken dann nach
hause gehen können das werde ich jetzt
auch machen ja auch eine ganze stunde
vor uns und ich würde sie nicht vergehen
deswegen gebe ich jetzt mal 20 zurück
sie hätten jetzt praktisch das was sie
haben fair aufgeteilt bin ich jetzt der
standort fallen oder wie es wie waren
die resultate bei diesen extremen die
die die empirischen regularien sehen
hier so aus dass sehr viele leute 10
franken übergeben
dass ein signifikanter prozentsatz von
menschen in ihrer position auch geld
zurückgeben also beispielsweise 20
franken
aber nicht alle es gibt auch einen
signifikanten prozentsatz von leuten die
die situation ausnützen und das geld
behalten mit dem 40 nach hause dann mit
40 nach hause gleich muss man auch sagen
das ist ja auch anonym also wir sehen
uns jetzt hier können unsere augen
schauen aber ihre experimente oder die
meisten experimente sind auch noch
niemand kennt sich nicht man begegnet
sich niemals wieder im leben das ja auch
wieder
also wenn man das experiment face to
face von angesicht zu angesicht machen
würde dann würde wahrscheinlich meine
prognose der regelfall darin bestehen
dass man zehn rüber gibt und der andere
20 zurückgeben
weil das hat extrem das aktiviert unsere
soziale motive sehr stark und es fällt
den leuten schwer so offen das vertrauen
quasi zu missbrauchen
wenn es aber anonym ist und darüber habe
ich gesprochen als über die anonyme
situation also wenn wir das im labor
durchführen dann kennen sich die partei
nicht die haben sich vorher nie gesehen
werden sich nachher nie sehen damit wir
quasi die hohe motivation in der
anonymen situation erfassen können ja
und dann kann man die situation so
variieren dass man untersucht welche
faktoren führen dazu dass zum beispiel
das vertrauen gestärkt wird dass das
vertrauen honoriert wird und so weiter
was sagt das ganze über den menschen
eigentlich aus dieses resultat gut dass
das zunächst einmal sagte aus dass es
sehr viele menschen gibt die vertrauen
haben in andere menschen sogar eine
anonyme andere menschen ja dass gerade
in unseren modernen gesellschaften ist
das der fall und dass das unter
unterscheiden sich die länder nicht
stark in alters und verschiedener
kulturen nein es gibt natürlich schon
kulturunterschiede aber aber in sagen
wir in europa in den usa da ist das
überall sehr ähnlich es wird extrem wir
vertrauen auch sehr viel fremden ja
gleichzeitig sagt es auch etwas darüber
aus dass vertrauen häufig aber nicht
immer honoriert wird es gibt einen nicht
unerheblichen prozentsatz von leuten die
vertrauen auch missbrauchen und das
spiel ist aus verschiedener hinsicht
heraus interessant ich mein 90 prozent
der menschheitsgeschichte wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass es dem modernen menschen
seit 30.000 jahren gibt haben wir keine
gerichte gehabt haben wir keine
unparteiischen richter gehabt es gab
keine polizei die mitgeholfen hat bei
der rechtsdurchsetzung dass die menschen
konnten keine verträge abschließen die
dann
vor gericht bestand hatten ja in der
modernen gesellschaft würde man ja hier
häufiger einen vertrag abschließen und
wir würden uns beide binden
dass ich zehn sende- und 27 zurück und
ist gut kontrolle ist besser zum
beispiel ja aber in 90 prozent der
menschheitsgeschichte gab es diese
vertrags institutionen nicht das heißt
wir mussten zurechtkommen
ohne diese institutionen und da blieb
nur vertrauen übrig und kooperation ist
vertrauen etwas irrationales das kann
man überhaupt nicht so sagen das ist per
se irrational sehr rational ich meine
wenn ich jemanden gut kenne
dann kann vertrauen eine völlig
rationale sache sein weil ich weil ich
da werde ich die person kenne weil ich
sie hundertmal beobachtet habe aber ist
dann vertrauen oder wissen wenn sie die
person also ist immer noch vertrauen
weil die möglichkeit besteht dass ich
rein gelegt werde
ja dies ist immer noch vertrauen aber
wenn ich jemandem vertrauen von dem ich
weiß dass er schon mehrfach das tiefste
als wenn die stadt verurteilt wurde
dann kann vertrauen schon sehr
irrational sein ja wenn sogar grüne
dagegen spreche ja ich frage das
deswegen weil es gibt ja ein hormon ein
vertrauen sondern kuschelhormon sagt man
dem auch das oxytocin und sie haben
selbst auch experimente gemacht und
geschaut wie sich das auswirkt darf
solche spiele also wenn man das als
nasenspray zum beispiel lernt sich zu
führt dann vertraut man viel eher das
ist ein hormon das in der
schwangerschaft beim stillen
ausgeschüttet wird stärkt die bindung ja
das heißt doch irgendwie das ist wir
sind das eher anfällig dafür glauben
nicht dass wir anfällig sind ich glaube
dass es biologische voraussetzungen
dafür gibt dass wir vertrauen
ja also es ist so dass das die biologie
eine große rolle spielt die menschlichen
verhalten nicht nur die gesellschaft
gesellschaft natürlich auch und
gerade im tierreich aber auch beim
menschen wie sich in diesem experiment
gezeigt hat hat eben haben bestimmte
biologische substanzen eine verhaltens
ändernde wirkung
in dem fall war es so dass wir eine
placebokontrollierte studie durchgeführt
haben
die hälfte der probanden hat ein placebo
bekommen die andere hälfte der probanden
hat oxytocin bekommen die probanden
selbst wussten nicht und auch die
experimentatoren mussten nicht sie waren
beide blind dort problems war eine
doppelblindstudie wer was bekommen hat
und wir haben festgestellt dass das
vertrauen größer wird wenn die leute
oxytocin bekommen haben das heißt bei
verhandlungsgesprächen könnte man das ja
irgendwie wenn man die leute
manipulieren möchte denn auch so ein
bisschen zu führen nein das glaube ich
nicht dass das funktionieren würde weil
es ist nicht so dass man das einfach so
versprechen versprechen kann im raum man
muss diese dass oxytocin sehr tief in
die nase hinein bringen sehr tief und
dann durchdringt es die
blut-hirn-schranke weil es ist ein
relativ großes molekül und wir wissen
bis heute nicht genau warum es aufgrund
seiner größe überhaupt in der lage ist
ins gehirn zu kommen wir wissen nur dass
es irgendwie rein kommt weil man das
auch im mit bildgebenden verfahren
messen konnte ich möchte mit diesem noch
über ein zweites experiment sprechen wir
haben jetzt über das vertrauen
gesprochen es gibt aber noch eine andere
menschliche eigenschaft die sich zeigt
nämlich fairness gerechtigkeitsempfinden
kann man auch sagen dazu gibt es ein
ganz berühmtes spiel aus der
spieltheorie nämlich das ultimatum
stellt das funktioniert auch mit geld
das das geht ungefähr so ich habe
erstmal diese 40 franken kann man sagen
ich kann entscheiden wie ich die auf
teile zwischen uns beiden
ich kann zum beispiel gegen 10 franken
geben und 30 für mich behalten sie haben
wir jetzt aber die position dass sie an
ein veto einlegen können auch sagen nee
das ist mir keine gerechte aufteilung
ich möchte diese zehn franken nicht und
dann verliere ich auch meine 30 richtig
können
was ist da rausgekommen bei diesem
experiment
ja dieses experiment wurde erstmals in
den frühen 80er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts in deutschland durchgeführt
und vielleicht muss ich zuerst jetzt
etwas sagen zur prognose für dieses
experiment was ist die verhaltens
prognose in diesem experiment und hier
muss man annahmen treffen wenn sie jetzt
ein völliger eigennütziges individuum
während und ich auch ein völliger
eigennütziges individuum wäre da sind
wir beide nur an geld interessiert sind
was wäre dann die prognose dann würden
sie mir in dem fall von den 40 franken
einen franken herüber schieben weil sie
wissen ich bin an geld interessiert und
ich würde einen franken vorziehen
gegenüber null franken
das heißt ich würde zu diesem einen
franken ja sagen
und weil sie wissen wenn sie wissen dass
ich nur an geld interessiert bin
sie wissen dass ich ja sagen würde
würden sich 39 franken für sich behalten
das heißt die prognose in diesem
experiment lautet dass sie fast alles
für sich nehmen wir fast nichts geben um
nicht das akzeptiere ja faktisch tritt
das ja praktisch nein es gibt
ausnahmesituationen wo das eintritt das
hat man in bestimmten gegenden der welt
beobachtet aber in den saisonalen
industrialisierten westlichen
gesellschaften aber auch in china und in
japan und überall wo das sozusagen in
modernen gesellschaften durchgeführt
wurde
werden zu geringe geldbeträge die man
vorgeschlagen hat per veto abgelehnt das
heißt die menschen lassen es sich nicht
gefallen mit so weniger abgespeist zu
werden und dieses experiment hat auch
eine lawine von folge experimenten
ausgelöst die dann eben gemeinsam auch
mit dem vertrauens experiment wo sie ja
auch sich fair verhalten können indem
sie wir freiwillig zum beispiel die
hälfte dessen was sie haben zurückgeben
diese experimente haben gezeigt dass das
motiv gerechtigkeit und fairness walten
zu lassen auch ein
mächtiges modell dass dieses
menschenbild vom humor ökonomie kuss vom
egoistischen nutzen maximieren mit dem
die wirtschaftswissenschaften lang
gerechnet haben mit diesem modell dass
das irgendwie realitätsfern ist dass wir
hatten noch mehrere motive also für die
meisten leute ist es realitätsfern es
gibt natürlich leute also ich würde so
sagen die die standard die leute nehmen
sind dann schon bereit also wenn sie
jetzt von 40 franken geht uns und sie
mir 10 geben da gibt's schon ein paar
leute die sagen lieber zehn wie gar
nichts
ja also es ist nicht jeder jeder der
weniger als 20 bekommt weniger als die
hälfte bekommt lädt ab da gibt es einen
trade off ja also ich frage mich was ist
mir lieber 10 franken zu haben oder gar
nichts zu haben und der gerechtigkeit
genüge getan zu haben
aber viele leute viel lassen sagen wir
so vielen leuten ich das was wert sie
bereite ressourcen zu verzichten um
faire zustände herzustellen und
interessant waren sich bei der
vorbereitung dass das nicht nur den
meisten menschen so geht sondern
anscheinend auch anzeichen dafür gibt
dass selbst bei tieren dieses fairness
empfinden gerechtigkeitsempfinden eine
rolle spielen es gibt ein ganz berühmtes
experiment des niederländischen
verhaltensforschers frans de waal dass
wir uns kurz anschauen es wir sehen zwei
kapuzineräffchen in getrennten käfigen
die beide eine aufgabe die selbe aufgabe
erfüllen müssen nämlich einen stein
annehmen und wieder zurückgeben
wir schauen uns kurz an was dann
passiert die kriegen nämlich eine
belohnung dafür entweder ein stück gurke
oder eine süße traube die sind natürlich
viel lieber haben und der eine kriegt
hier ein stück gurke und der andere der
zweite rechts bekommt jetzt für dieselbe
aufgabe eine süße leckerei bezahlen
der andere sieht das natürlich macht die
aufgabe noch mal kriegt wieder nur eine
brücke jetzt schauen was passiert
[Gelächter]
der rebellierten nochmal dasselbe der
andere
er führt die aufgabe kriegt viele eine
trage er testet jetzt der stein über
alles richtig gemacht hat einen fehler
gemacht nein kriegt noch mal eine gurke
moritz rastet heraus was fressen einfach
unfair
also wunderschönes experiment das ist
wirklich lustig heißt das dass das diese
kapuzineräffchen ein gerechtigkeitssinn
haben gut für die meisten verhaltens
tendenzen und gefühle die menschen haben
gibt es ja evolutionäre vorläufer bei
unseren vorfahren das mag nicht völlig
gleich weit entwickelt sein oder auf
sich auf gleiche weise ausdrücken aber
was natürlich dieses experiment sagt ist
es gibt so etwas wie zumindest
frustration darüber weniger zu bekommen
als das andere ja hier geht es ja in den
sozialen vergleich hier geht das ist ja
nicht ganz das ultimatum spiel hier geht
es ja darum dass der eine affe die
traube bekommt die die affen dadurch
viel lieber haben wie die gurke und er
muss und der andere bekommt nur die
gurke und das findet der affe der die
gurke bekommt anscheinend wir können
wissen wir können nicht reinschauen
er kann nicht sprechen wir wissen nicht
was ungerecht empfindet aber er finde
das absolut frustrierend und diese
frustration kommt hier zum ausdruck und
das zeigt doch dass dieser soziale
vergleichs prozess der hier stattfindet
der eine bekommt mehr als ich für das
gleiche getan dass das etwas sehr tief
sitzendes ist ja ich habe mich noch
gefragt die affen haben ja gurken und
trauben
wir haben es mit geld gespielt welche
rolle spielt denn das medium geld oder
anders gefragt wie verändert das unsere
entscheidung dass es hier um so etwas
abstraktes wie wie geld geht befördert
das vielleicht auch
den egoismus die also was wir wissen ist
dass die menschen wenn es bei geld eher
eigennützig handeln als weil es wenn es
darum geht andere dinge zu teilen oder
in anderen domänen altruistisch zu
helfen beispielsweise das heißt weniger
altruistisch wenn sie uns wenn es sich
gehört haben ja also war es gibt hier
und es gibt hier studien die zeigen dass
das man zum beispiel großzügiger ist mit
seiner zeit also die leute sind eher
bereit zeit herzugeben als geld
herzugeben
ja man sieht das ja auch zum beispiel
wenn menschen freiwillig bei vereinen
mit arbeiten die die eine soziale
funktion haben dann geben die menschen
ja eigentlich auch eine sehr wertvolle
ressource diesem verein und der
gesellschaft damit sie geben ihre arbeit
ihre zeit ihre wertvolle zeit dafür her
und anscheinend ist es so dass wir eher
bereit sind zeit herzugeben als geld her
zu gut da kann man ja auch sagen da ist
eine direkte interaktion man bekommt die
anerkennung zurück das macht irgendwie
glücklich das ist richtig aber selbst
wenn ich also wir können es gibt ja auch
ein sogenanntes diktator spielt ja dass
diktator spiel geht so ich hab ich habe
20 franken
und ich kann die beliebig aufteilen
zwischen ihnen und mir und sie haben gar
keine rolle sie sind komplett passiv und
ich kann alles behalten
ich kann ihn 10 10 aufteilen ich kann
machen was ich will und wie es ist nach
wie vor anonym
und dieses dieses dieses status spiel
das kann man nun machen mit geld oder
mit anderen gütern zum beispiel mit das
heißt sie können ihr geld geben oder
nicht oder sie haben ist immer eine
entscheidung die sie müsse nichts
akzeptieren was sie bekommen
ich könnte es nicht einmal weg ablehnen
ja
und in diesem diktator spielen kann ich
all diese dinge die sie jetzt vorher
angesprochen haben mitglied beim verein
bei der freiwilligen mitarbeit in
vereinen eine rolle spielen nicht ich
fühle mich dort vielleicht sozial
aufgehoben ich fühle mich ich gehe gern
hin weil dort leute sind mit denen ich
gerne zu tun habe
das kann ich alles mit kontrollieren
sozusagen indikator spiele und selbst
dort beobachtet man dass menschen eher
bereit sind physische güter zu teilen
als als geld zu teilen
das kann auch ich vermute das hat auch
gewisse evolutionäre ursachen dass zum
beispiel evolutionär gesehen hat ja das
teilen von futter also eine große rolle
gespielt food sharing also wenn man wenn
die menschen die jäger und sammler auf
die jagd gegangen sind und ein großes
stück wild erlegt haben dann musste man
das irgendwie verteilen und dir das
aufteilen von lebensmitteln hat in der
menschheitsgeschichte eine große rolle
gespielt und deshalb hat zum beispiel
fleisch fleisch war eine wertvolle
ressource ist es ja heute immer noch
fleisch wurde häufig geteilt den bei
diesen jägern und zandern ja sie sehen
wie einfach zu abstrakt dass es
irgendwie unsere gleich biologischen
fairness empfindungen hat ansprechen
kann möglich es ist natürlich sehr
spekulative hier sage aber dass eine
plausible hypothese würde ich sagen ja
man sieht und die experimente die die
liegen uns ja wirklich sehr empirisch
und es geht sogar so weit dass sie nicht
nur solche spiele machen an ihrem
institut sondern auch den leuten ins
gehirn gucken sie haben sich ein gehirn
scanner angeschafft jetzt ist die frage
was sieht man da und kann man
gesellschaftliche probleme lösen die
welt besser machen was ja eigentlich ihr
treiben das motiv ist aus erkundung wenn
man den leuten ins gericht und guckt
also die neuroökonomie die sie hier
ansprechen die kombination von
wirtschaftswissenschaft von verhaltens
von studium des verhaltens des menschen
und die neurowissenschaft als die
kombination ist grundlagenforschung
ich würde ich glaube nicht dass wir da
unmittelbar soziale probleme damit lösen
können dass wir den menschen ins gehirn
schauen was wir aber schon können ist
und das drückt sich auch darin aus dass
ich zum beispiel viele einladungen
bekommen habe auf psychiatrischen
kongressen vorzutragen
wir können durchaus den menschen
individuell helfen also es gibt ja viele
krankheiten die sich auch dadurch
ausdrücken dass die menschen sehr sieht
sich sehr speziell verhalten ja also
sehr impulsiv beispielsweise oder sehr
sehr antisozial wie auch immer und die
kombination von vom studio sondern die
kombination von verhaltensstudien und
hier in studien die hilft uns natürlich
schon viel besser zu verstehen was beim
einzelnen menschen vorgeht und was
verschiedene ursachen seien könnten ja
darum ist ja heute auch in der
psychiatrie ein
der tipp die die kinos um zu einer
wissenschaft zu erkennen ja weil man
natürlich daran dann gezielt auch durch
medikamente ansetzen kann wenn man weiß
welche gehirnregionen zum beispiel
betroffen sie ein
ich habe schon ihre anliegen
angesprochen mit möglichst
interdisziplinäres arbeiten dass viele
erkenntnisse aus der psychologie in die
auch in die ökonomie geholt dann die
neurowissenschaft um die welt zu
verbessern die die zeitschrift bilanz
land ist immer hat professor gutmensch
das war so gesehen abschätzig gehen ab
stellt sich gewalt aber der sss trifft
es trifft natürlich ihr treiben das
motiv das schon im studium irgendwie da
war in wien sie haben in wien studiert
doktoriert sich habilitiert auch unter
dem einfluss von sigmund freud natürlich
psychoanalyse und wien
vielleicht ein bisschen deswegen nahezu
100 psychologie hin wurden dann 1994
professor in zürich haben zahlreiche
preise bekommen ehrendoktorate professur
angebote von princeton wörtlich
cambridge oxford namhafte universitäten
die besten der welt werden immer wieder
als kandidat für den nobelpreis
gehandelt sind dann aber in zürich
geblieben mit ihrer frau und zwei
kindern sind seit januar schweizer habe
ich erfahren sind auch schweizer auch
schweizer genannten der österreicher
sind in vorarlberg geboren und für
aufsehen gesorgt haben sie auch 2012 als
sie direktor wurden des ubs
international center of economics in
society
dieses center hat zum anliegen die
forschung zu stärken und den transfer
von wissenschaft in die gesellschaft zu
leisten und haben dann 100 millionen
franken von der ubs bekommen anlässlich
des 150 jahre sie habe nicht romandie
hat das institution lehre bekommen
das institut für volkswirtschaftslehre
aber es gab einen großen protest es gab
eine protestbriefe namhafte ökonomen
ökonomen haben unterschrieben profis
frei zum beispiel market osterloh weil
man gedacht hat dass jetzt ist die
unabhängigkeit der forschung gefährdet
das hat diese wogen haben sich geglättet
aber im rückblick gibt es diese paar
jahre zurück würden sie sagen sie haben
einen fehler gemacht damals was hätten
sie was würden sie heute anders machen
und das kommunizieren ich würde gar
nichts anders machen mit einer ausnahme
ich würde den vertrag von vornherein
öffentlich machen damit man sieht dass
hier eigentlich alles mit rechten dingen
zugegangen ist ich meine da die
errichtung des ubs centers ist eine
riesige erfolgsgeschichte und all die
kritiker müssten eigentlich mittlerweile
anerkennen dass das eine
erfolgsgeschichte geworden ist
da gibt es eben noch viele kritiker nein
ich das heißt das ist eigentlich
eingeschlafen und da und wir haben da
die mit dem institut für
volkswirtschaftslehre ist es gelungen
von einem wie soll ich sagen er noch
nicht an der spitze befindlichen
institut zu einem der besten
europäischen
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen instituten
zu werden auch mit hilfe dieser spende
und die ich glaube sogar im rückblick
wird das so sein wenn man das zehn oder
20 jahren einmal betrachtet dass diese
spende einen historischen wandel
eingeleitet hat dass die universitäten
viel unbefangener in der lage sind auch
private spenden zu generieren sofern sie
in der lage sind und das sind sie die
unabhängigkeit und freiheit von
wissenschaft und lehre zu garantieren
und das war bei uns zu jedem zeitpunkt
gegeben ja also das war ich dich ich
hätte mich gar nicht eingelassen auf
etwas das meine eigene freiheit zum
beispiel einschränkt und ich habe selbst
eine studie eine banken kritische studie
publiziert jahre später das heißt hier
gibt es überhaupt keine einschränkung
und das ist eigentlich eine ganz tolle
sache geworden
es gab viele vorbehalte und jetzt hat
sich wir haben nirgendwo soviele
vorbehalt dies übertrieben ich meine es
ist es sie finden natürlich an sie
sie finden bei allem ein individuum oder
ein paar die dagegen sind ja und das ist
mehr als 100 personen hier aber in der
schweiz ja aber nicht aber nicht in der
schweiz
also wenn wir eine abstimmung gemacht
hätten an der fakultät für
wirtschaftswissenschaften hätten wir
sowjetische zustimmungsraten bekommen
für diese fördere
wenig überzeugt ja weil die bei die
studenten den studenten war völlig klar
dass sie davon profitieren die man die
haben heute
wir haben mit diesen mitteln sieben
professuren finanzieren können
also was ich mit als assistenzprofessor
meter eingerechnet und und es ganz
hervorragend weltweiter anerkannte
wissenschaftler zions gekommen die wir
sonst nie hätten anziehen können ja da
ist wirklich eine erfolgsgeschichte das
kann man sagen
ich möchte mit ihnen jetzt sozusagen zum
kernpunkt zu ihrer kernthese kommen wenn
ich das so sagen darf und über den
menschen reden und ob die eigentlich ein
egoist ist von natur aus oder ein auto
ist und sie sagen diese frage ist
irgendwie falsch gestellt es kommt
darauf an in welchen bedingungen die
menschen mehr handel und welche
spielregeln gelten
und je nachdem zeigt sich die eine oder
die andere seite und jetzt möchte ich
mit ihm müssen darüber diskutieren wie
man das verhalten der menschen lenken
kann und unter welchen bedingungen denn
das altruistische im menschen das gute
zum vorschein kommt ja gut ich meine
hier muss man unterscheiden zwischen
zwei arten von einflussnahmen auf den
menschen das eine ist können wir die
grundlegende motivation des menschen
verändern
ja und das glaube ich das können wir
beim ausgewachsenen menschen kaum mehr
machen wir können das aber bei kindern
machen
wir wissen also beispielsweise aus
studien dass kinder die selbst in einer
pro sozialen umgebung aufwachsen
das heißt pro sozial heißt ja in einer
umgebung in der sie anderen vertrauen in
denen in der das vertrauen erwidert wird
in der es jemanden gibt der sich um sie
kümmert der für sie da ist also wie sich
gegenseitig ich würd sagen so wie es in
einer guten familie
zugeht und sie werden sich wundern wie
viele familien das ist zwar nicht die
mehrheit aber es gibt trotzdem viele
familien da wird zum beispiel kindern
nie etwas vorgelesen bekommen nie eine
gute nacht geschichte vorgelesen ja die
mutter ist vielleicht geschieden und
muss gleichzeitig arbeiten es hat hat
wenig zeit ist permanent gestresst und
da gibt es eine studie zum beispiel aus
deutschland die gezeigt hat wenn man
hier diesen familien einen eine person
zur verfügung gestellt die für das kind
einen tag einen halben tag in der woche
da ist ja in dem kinder aufgaben macht
einfach da ist dass das dazu führt dass
die kinder nach einem jahr erheblich
prosoziale sind sie vertrauen anderen
menschen mehr sie sind eher bereit zu
teilen
sie sind in diesem vertrauen spielt er
bereit zurückzugeben
nach einem halben tag pro woche nach
einem halben tag pro woche
das heißt mittlerweile ich habe gehört
die studie ist von herrn falk aus bonn
gemacht worden und der einmal in zürich
bei mir ob assistent war dass die neuen
resultate sogar zeigen dass die kinder
die an dieser studie teilgenommen haben
sogar mit mit einem höheren prozentsatz
ins gymnasium kommen ja unglaublich das
heißt ich kann wenn ich früh genug
eingreife auch grundlegende motivation
beim menschen ändern und diese
grundlegenden motivationen die weil das
sind prosoziale motivationen in dem fall
die sind für die gesellschaft natürlich
sehr nützlich weil ein individuum dass
er bereit ist zum beispiel vertrauen zu
honorieren
das wird auch am arbeitsmarkt
erfolgreicher sein das wird ein
produktiver arbeitnehmer seien aber das
spricht alles dafür dass wir viel mehr
in die frühkindliche beziehung
erziehung investieren nicht gut das ist
aber wie soll ich sagen das ist eine
fast eine leidenschaft von mir dass ich
dafür eintreten dass wir mehr
investieren in frühkindliche erziehung
ja und zwar bevor die kinder in die
schule kommen ja also es geht hier darum
dass es uns gelingt bildungsferne
schichten
na ja sozusagen heran an heranzuführen
an diese unter kindern eine ausstattung
mit zu geben an verhaltensweisen an
motivation einfach so erfolgreich machen
im leben dafür fragen was das konkret
heißt kita pflicht
na ja ich würde ich würde mal ich würde
mal versuchen mit möglichst wenig zwang
zu arbeiten damit wieder angeboten zu
arbeiten aber de facto ist es natürlich
so dass das geld das verursacht immer
gegenreaktionen die pflicht ich mein
denken sie zurück als die allgemeine
schulpflicht eingeführt wurde in europa
oder in den usa
das ist nicht widerstands frei gegangen
insbesondere die bäuerliche bevölkerung
war nicht erfreut darüber dass die g 6 7
8 und 10 jährigen kinder nicht mehr
bauernhof mithelfen konnten sondern in
die schule gehen mussten
das heißt aber wir wissen heute dass
diese allgemeine schulpflicht eine
unglaublich wichtige maßnahme war für
unsere gesellschaften ja und von aber
man muss natürlich solche grundlegenden
reformen behutsam angehen und versuchen
möglichst mit angeboten zu arbeiten und
wenn wir haben ja in der schweiz
mittlerweile initiativen die darauf
hinarbeiten mehr in die frühkindliche
betreuung zu investieren und das ist gut
angelegtes geld weil weil ich hier auch
automatisch die menschen zu
produktiveren teilnehmern an der
gesellschaft mache und die ungleichheit
verringere das heißt die gesellschaft
wohl profitiert und die menschen
profitieren
es ist eine wenn man so sagen wie man so
schön sagt eine win win situation ja
eine langfristige ist die langfristigen
lässt das habe ich sie unterbrochen bei
ihren gedanken sie haben gesagt okay
wenn die motivation ändern möchte dann
muss man ganz früh ansetzen ja aber
später kann man wahrscheinlich das
verhalten danach er ohne zwang ihn
bestimmt ja man kann natürlich auch viel
später noch sehr viel erreichen also man
kann
wir haben ja hier gibt es ja die ganze
nation literatur aus dem bereich des
behavioral economics die die zeigt dass
man menschliches verhalten auf
verschiedene art und weisen steuern kann
ersten sie wasser für wir haben ein
einspieler vorbereitet
die videosequenz wir schreiben und sagen
was dieses nacho dieses stückes denn
eigentlich bedeutet wie das funktioniert
ok
vielleicht war es ein findiger putzmann
der sie erfunden hat auf jeden fall
erhöht sie die treffsicherheit
diese kleine pflege hier
[Musik]
ein sanftes schubser mit einer großen
wirkung
ein typischer land reist schubsen oder
stupsen auf englisch in ihrem buch haben
die autoren carson steen und roger
taylor den begriff geprägt
ein match ist ein kleiner helfer der
unsere aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht und
unser verhalten beeinflusst mit einem
nachspiel mich also irgendwer in die
richtige richtung lenken
wenn ich etwa in einer kantine zuerst an
der salatbar vorbeikomme und dann erst
ab fleisch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass ich den salat wähle
entscheidungs architektur nennen das die
autoren nicht immer sind die schubser so
subtil um mich vom rauchen abzuhalten
versucht man es gern auch mit
schocktherapie
[Musik]
überhaupt in sachen gesundheit stehe ich
unter strenger beobachtung die fitness
nur ist erbarmungslos und macht mich zum
sklaven meines schlechten gewissen weil
ich mein innerer schweinehund wäre
einfach zu faul um gesund zu leben
energie zu sparen oder die steuern
rechtzeitig zu bezahlen ja fair ist das
nicht eiskalte manipulation was hier gut
ich mein verhaltenssteuerung findet und
fand immer schon statt
ich meine es gibt eine ganze industrie
die werbeindustrie die das immer schon
gemacht hat ja und jetzt beim nation
geht es darum dass auch der staat
sondern verstärkt aufgefordert ist
darüber nachzudenken ob man vielleicht
solche maßnahme zur verhaltenssteuerung
nicht doch auch einsetzen könnte und
hier muss man feststellen dass die das
matching natürlich gegenüber anderen
maßnahmen deutliche vorteile haben kann
zum beispiel wenn ich eine steuer habe
eine steuer muss jeder bezahlen der
sozusagen die betreffende aktivität
unternimmt beispielsweise autofahren und
co2 steuer 2 steuer beispielsweise und
ich kann der steuer nicht ausweichen bei
matschig ist ein typischer weise so dass
das niemand die menschen zwingt sie
können dem ausweichen und so und wenn es
der gesetzgeber irgendwelche nazi sein
für die im demokratischen prozess
diskutiert worden sind und beschlossen
worden sind ist dagegen überhaupt nichts
einzuwenden
das interessante ist ja dass jetzt
plötzlich eine manipulations debatte
ausbricht bei wenn der staat das macht
während
die private industrie die seit 100
jahren indem sie werbung sendet indem
sie die die produkte richtig präsentiert
da gibt es eine ganze industrie die sich
damit beschäftigt wie man das verhalten
des konsumenten gesteuert
da hat niemand protestiert ja also
findet eine gewisse ungleichbehandlung
statt
man kann sagen wenn der staat macht gibt
es keinen wettbewerb der hauptseite
sozusagen als monopolen und dann wieso
das starren wir also wenn der staat eine
steuerlich ist es besser in der stadt
eine besteuerte
sie zwingt eine steuer zu zahlen oder
ihnen die möglichkeit gibt auch nein zu
sagen nein jetzt im unterschied zur
wirtschaft dachte ich war da
unterschiedliche unternehmen dann
unterschiedliche anreize oder nachos
setzen können mich unterschiedlich in
unterschiedliche richtungen
beeinflussten der sender der nächste
dran dass sie trotzdem den bürgern
fetten bürger essen und das werden das
ist ja nur weil sie sozusagen bei mir
schlecht dass beim wenn sie sozusagen
eine sie können die kentucky fried
chicken oder sie können zu einer bürger
für anderen bürger firma kommen und die
sind beide gleichungen gesund ja also
diese art von wettbewerb bringt ja da
auch nichts erfinden sie dann muss das
irgendwie transparent machen er
natürlich ein match schauen sie ist wenn
ihr wenn ich mich wenn ich mir überlege
will ich wie wenig verhalten steuern
dann muss sich jeder entscheidungsträger
die die frage stellen wie er das macht
und das machen die leute millionenfach
jeden tag in ihm unternehmen fragen sie
sich wie kann ich meine produkte besser
verkaufen wie kann ich meinen
lieferanten dazu bringen dass wir
bessere produkte zu billigeren preisen
liefert da ist das sind alle der leute
damit beschäftigt das verhalten von
anderen irgendwie zu steuern ja deshalb
ist daran nichts verwerfliches jahr und
und jetzt ist es so dass wir beim staat
eben
weil die häfeli genehmigt den
werkzeugkasten den wir zur verfügung
haben in bezug auf verhaltenssteuerung
groß erweitert hat auch die frage
stellen können oder müssen wann wollen
wir welche dieser maßnahmen verwenden
gibt es bei ihnen grenzen irgendein v wo
sie sagen würden da geht das zu weit mit
dem rating da sorgt das sollte man nicht
machen
und ich habe mir das zu wenig überlegt
wahrscheinlich wird es schon grenzen
geben aber wenn es beispielsweise in der
schweiz in einer volksabstimmung ich
gebe ihnen ein beispiel nehmen sie an
in einer gemeinde oder in einem kanton
soll darüber befunden werden ob es so
etwas gibt wie eine bei der
energieversorgung dass der der grüne
tarif sozusagen der standardtarif
während ja ich kann mich unters
entscheiden zwischen grüner energie und
graue energie sagen wir ja die energie
so welt verschmutzen da aber vielleicht
billiger für mich grüne energie ist
weniger co2 ausstoßen und damit besser
für die umwelt aber ging hier kann man
zum beispiel die frage ein match würde
jetzt hier zum beispiel sein was ist die
standardeinstellung ja da konnte jeder
staatsbürger hätte das recht auch das zu
ändern ich kann sozusagen zu wechseln
zum grundtarif stadt zum grünen tarif
einfach das häkchen aber in stellung vor
einstellung ist der grüne tarif und man
weiß aus vielen studien dass wenn man
die voreinstellungen beim grünen tarif
hat das dann viel mehr leute den grünen
tarif wählen weil man einfach aus
trägheit beim grünen tarif bleibt oder
nicht nur aus träger die sich sogar so
dass viele leute wenn man sie fragt
aktiv fragt wollen sie den grünen oder
den grauen tarif dann sagen viele ja
eigentlich will ich den grünen aber um
das umzusetzen also um meine intention
handlungen folgen zu lassen da gibt es
noch so viele hindernisse zu überwinden
dass ich es nie machen und all diesen
leuten nimmt man sozusagen die
entscheidung ab indem man den grünen
tarif zum standardtarif macht
würden sagen man hilft den menschen
damit ihre eigenen präferenzen
interessen irgendwie auch handlungs
wirksam zu machen oder wenn sie sagen
eigentlich für all diejenigen die
eigentlich diesen tarif wollen ist das
so
jetzt gibt es natürlich auch andere die
vielleicht in grauen wollen aber einfach
zu träge sind da zum von grünen zum
grauen zu wechseln
das gibt es auch aber wenn das bei einer
volksabstimmung zum beispiel
demokratisch entschieden wird dass man
das so machen okay was ist dagegen
einzuwenden ich muss ich sagen dass ich
sagen ja dass auch vor in eben der
organspende also wenn es darum geht ob
er organspender sein sollen oder nicht
ob wir dazu eine zustimmung geben müssen
oder ob es wie eine voreinstellung gibt
und wie alle organ spenderinnen und
spender sind wenn wir nicht wieder
sprechen jetzt das tief diese
widerspruchslösung führen sie glaube ich
plädiere ja ich bin durchaus ein
anhänger der widerspruchslösung ist wird
er in deutschland momentan auch breit
diskutiert und in der schweiz ist eine
initiative lanciert in der schweiz ist
sogar eine initiative lanciert eine
milde die wie die widerspruchslösung
würde sicher das angebot an
organspendern erhöhen und dadurch leben
retten
und ich hoffe dass die initiative
erfolgreich sein wird dabei wir werden
sehen es gibt ja auch sehr viele leute
die die da einwände haben die muss man
durchaus ernst nehmen ich kann das
verstehen dass menschen hier
empfindlichkeiten haben und das muss man
im demokratischen dialog dann hieß es
ist ja nicht nur moralisch und schritten
sondern auch empirisch es gibt ja
anscheinend auch länder wo es gezeigt
hat dass die spende raten nicht nach
oben gegangen ist und da gibt es in der
schweiz kantone tessin muss spendete
viel höher ist aber die haben auch nicht
das ist das weiter es ist wirklich
könnte eine eigene sendung dazu machen
muss man vielleicht sagen an dieser
stelle und auch moralischen in so einem
grundrecht
sozusagen einzugreifen
persönlichkeitsrecht das nach ich habe
mir das nicht gut überlegt ob ich jetzt
spenden spielen das sagen möchte nicht
nach meinem tod wird man gut ich meine
angenommen und kann man das problem so
betrachtet man kann das moralisch ist
situation auch so betrachten
ich meine die gesamtanzahl an spendern
jan gesamte anzahl an verfügbaren organe
und das ist im grunde genommen so etwas
wie ein öffentliches gut in dem sinne
dass dass es einen pool von organen gibt
und die werden jetzt irgendwie stehen
zur verfügung die frage ist wie und
jeder jeder der sozusagen anspruch hat
auf so eine organspende kann kommen und
diese organspende in anspruch nehmen
wenn das organ da ist ja jeder
hier musste ich auch dann letztlich
jeder fragen will ich ein
trittbrettfahrer sein will ich selbst
sozusagen organe in anspruch nehmen wenn
ich ich bin ich wenn ich bin ich selbst
nicht bereit bin zu geben
man kann das auch aus dieser perspektive
betrachten es ist eine art
trittbrettfahrer problem hier auch ja
und eine zwischenlösung könnte hier auch
lauten dass man eine art reziprozität
lösung hat dass die leute die freiwillig
sich sozusagen melden für die
organspende dann den vorzug bekommen
wenn sie selbst ein organ brauchen da
würde man das an das eigeninteresse
appellieren dass sie sind verschiedene
möglichkeiten die man hier hat das ist
aber es ist wirklich interessant sie
haben von diesem werkzeugkasten geredet
den sind sie haben aus
verhaltenserkennung und jetzt möchten
wir versuchen gegen ende der sendung den
letzten tag zu nutzen und um auf die
wirklichen globalen großen probleme zu
gucken und inwiefern uns diese werkzeuge
helfen können da etwas zu bewirken weil
es ist ja so bei diesen großen globalen
problemen da gibt es so etwas wie
verantwortung die fusion also jeder ist
irgendwie teilen des problems
klimawandel zum beispiel oder aber
keiner möchte voran
der dumme sein und wettbewerbs nachteile
in kauf nehmen wenn die anderen nicht
mitmachen und so weiter
und jetzt haben wir aber seit einigen
wochen beobachten wie ein neues phänomen
seit greta thunberg nämlich dass sie
diese klimademonstration weltumspannend
jugendliche nicht nur jugendlichen gehen
auf die straße wir sehen hier
eindrückliche bilder von bern vor einer
woche wie sie hier marschieren was denkt
der verhaltensökonom finanziert was da
gerade passiert ja gut das ist zunächst
einmal ist man beeindruckt dass hier so
eine bewegung entstanden ist und weil
und und offensichtlich hat es hier nur
eines funkens bedurfte um diese bewegung
auszulösen weltweit und ich bin
überrascht dass das jetzt so entstanden
ist so schnell und ich hätte ihn nicht
vermutet dass das hier so schnell etwas
entsteht aber offensichtlich hat hier im
untergrund der gesellschaft jetzt schon
etwas länger rumort wo leute ohne das
ist öffentlich geworden ist ja es ist ja
so dass das hier in der jungen
generation anscheinend ein wandel
stattgefunden hat den wir vorher gar
nicht so wahrgenommen haben das aber
wenn man natürlich hingehört hat ich
habe das bei meinen eigenen kindern
gespürt dass die begonnen haben dann
plötzlich weniger fleisch zu essen oder
oder oder oder
vegetarisch sich zu ernähren wie hat
sich ihre kinder ich frage ja gut das
sind jetzt anfang 20 kurz bevor sie also
mein sohn ist 19 eine tochter ist 23 und
und auf anscheinend ist das ein
massenphänomen sozusagen dass das bei
vielen da war hat es dann nur noch einen
einen funken gebraucht um das feuer zu
entfachen
grundsätzlich faszinierend mich diese
art von kollektiven aktionen generell
weil weil die notwendig sind häufig
notwendig sind um größere
gesellschaftliche reformen durchzusetzen
sei es wenn es um den kampf gegen
diktaturen geht oder jetzt um den
klimawandel
ich meine hier geht es um ein sehr
großes menschheitsprobleme und was sich
hier natürlich zeigt die seine eine
grund wahrheit die verhaltensökonomen
wie soll ich sagen
doch unter anderem natürlich auch
dokumentiert haben
das team das den menschen nicht nur
eigennützig sind nicht ich meine wenn
ich schaue selbst dich selbst wie diese
kinder die jetzt auf die straße gehen
die ezb anfang 20 sender oder kurz die
zirka 20 jahre alt sind 8 15 bis 20
jahre alt sind
selbst die und in der schweiz ja ich
glaube nicht dass die persönlich groß
leiden würden den klimawandel
ehrlich gesagt nein das ziel dass die
haben ist in gewissem sinn etwas
größeres das heißt es weist über ihre
eigenen engen interessen hinaus und das
ist eine form von würde sagen ja es in
form von altruistischen verhalten
aber jetzt muss die politik irgendwas
machen und irgendwie kommt das ganze nur
schleppend voran jeder spielt sich dem
anderen die bälle zu man möchte schon
handeln aber nur unter der bedingung
dass die anderen auch handeln und china
machte was sie wollen und so weiter das
spiel wie wie geht man mit dieser
kollektiven
verantwortung konnte ich mein wissen
letztlich werden wir in der klimafrage
keine großen fortschritte machen können
wenn nicht die ganz großen player
mitmachen
das ist vor allem die usa wo der
durchschnittliche us bürger doppelt so
viel co2 co2 ausstoß beitrag wieder
durchschnittliche schweizer bürger
beispielsweise ja weil die usa stark
hinterherhinken
hier bei den maßnahmen und natürlich
dank china aber was heißt das für uns
für die schweiz jetzt dass wir sagen
wird solange die usa nichts machen
können wir mal ich glaube ich glaube
dass es hier so etwas gibt wie ich nehme
das einmal politik als biologisch das
heißt wir werden zwar wenn wir in der
schweiz massnahmen ergreifen nicht per
se die co2-emissionen so stark
reduzieren können dass das einen
merkbaren einfluss auf das weltklima hat
aber es ist ein bisschen so was wie ein
feuer entfachen es ist die politische
spiel over heißt wenn sie in der schweiz
passiert und wenn sie in anderen
kleineren ländern passiert zum beispiel
klein ist jetzt auch deutschland ist
nicht ganz so klein aber immer noch
weltweit gesehen klein wenn oder wenn
sie in der eu passiert dann dann hat das
so zu sagen dass etwas eher mund hat all
die kräfte in den anderen ländern die
auch dafür eintreten so vorbildfunktion
ist hat eine art vorbildfunktion also
das ist eine wichtige einsicht aus der
verhaltensökonomie ist auch dass die
menschen bedingt kooperativ sind
bedingte kooperation heißt ich bin
bereit meinen beitrag zu einem
öffentlichen gut zu leisten wenn die
anderen ihren beitrag auch leisten
und wenn hier einige voranschreiten dann
haben sie diese vorbildfunktion und
ermuntern andere auch mitzumachen
und das meine ich mit politik als
biologe
das heißt es wird dann die bewegung wird
größer und ich bin ja grundsätzlich
eigentlich ein optimist ich glaube auch
da der tramp ismus geht einmal vorbei
und die usa werden wieder zur vernunft
kommen und weil wenn die nicht mitmachen
in dem bereich dann dann dann fällt
entscheidende spieler auf der welt
ja das ist china und indien ja gut ich
meine das problem ist ja deshalb auch so
kompliziert weil es ja nicht nur um ein
öffentliches gut geht sondern auch darum
wer die lasten trägt der produktion
dieses öffentlichen gut ist das
öffentliche gut besteht darin den
klimawandel zu verhindern und die die
leute in indien oder die die indischen
vertreter und die chinesischen vertreter
sagen natürlich zu recht ihr habt jetzt
200 jahre lang
grenzenlos dazu beitragen können hier
emissionen zu tätigen und habt euch
dadurch einen wohlstand gesichert wir
wohl nach wohlstand haben irgendwie auch
zurecht oder natürlich ist das
gerechtfertigt aber darum gibt es ja
auch die idee hier praktisch diejenigen
zu entschädigen teilweise ja also es
gibt ja von ökonomen vorschläge dass man
gerade den entwicklungsländern unter die
arme greift das die zwar auch ihren
beitrag leisten aber aber dass man da
auch gleichzeitig hilfestellung leistet
durch durch de facto durch
entschädigungszahlungen die an diese
länder gehen
ich finde dieses problem klimawandel
deswegen auch so so symptomatisch für
die situation weil sie irgendwie dieses
problem doch noch etwas abstrakt ist wie
sie sagen es ähnlich wie das geld man
spürt ja nicht wirklich direkt denn den
einfluss oder den schaden man spürte
nicht am eigenen eigenen leib jetzt noch
als das braucht so etwas wie
langfristiges denken dass uns menschen
irgendwie schwer fällt das sieht man
auch in der wirtschaft bei den
quartalszahlen und so weiter bei den
boni wo sich ja für langfristige boni
politisieren und zwar für mich die frage
wie lernen wir menschen langfristig zu
denken wir lernen wie so etwas wie
geduld auch darüber haben sich viel viel
geforscht
gut also es ist ja so dass das wir
menschen die neigung haben risiken die
die in der zukunft liegen eher zu
akzeptieren sondern da gibt das wissen
wir aus verhaltens experimente
also wenn ich ihnen die wahl gebe
zwischen 100 franken sicher zu haben
oder 200 franken mit einer 50 50
wahrscheinlichkeit also mit 50 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit bekommen sie 200 mit
50 prozent bekommen sie gar nichts dann
wählen die meisten menschen die hundert
frank sicheren franken ja wenn ich aber
sage was ist ihnen lieber 200 franken in
fünf jahren mit einer 50 50
wahrscheinlichkeit oder 100 sichere
franken in fünf jahren dann wählen sehr
viele leute die lotterie interessant ja
das heißt wir sind eher bereit
unsicherheit zu akzeptieren in der
zukunft liegt und das ist natürlich ein
riesiges problem beim klimawandel weil
die konsequenzen des klimawandels in der
zukunft liegen die kosten des
klimawandels und liegen in der zukunft
und gleichzeitig gibt es eine andere
tendenz die dem entgegen arbeitet je
hochfrequenter ich negative ereignisse
erleben desto risikoaverser werde ich
also beispielsweise um das zu
illustrieren was das heißt
wenn ich täglich wenn ich wenn ich
investiere im aktienmarkt und ich schaue
die kurse täglich an und da geht es
häufig runter das ist wie ein verlust
und es geht aber auch wieder häufiger
auf
aber diese häufige erfahrung dass es
runter gibt
die führt dazu dass die menschen
risikoaverser werden also das risiko
scheuen das risiko scheuen und menschen
die nur einmal im jahr die aktienkurse
anschauen die sind weniger risiko wäre
es ja das heißt je hochfrequenter ich
temporäre negative ereignisse wahrnehmen
desto risikoscheuer werde ich das wird
dass die implikation davon ist das wenn
es jetzt nacheinander viele verschiedene
sommer gibt die extrem heiß sind die
dürre auslösen und ich das mit dem
klimawandel in verbindung bringen kann
dann sind die leute erheblich mehr
bereit welche den klimawandel sozusagen
hochfrequent in gewissem sinne erleben
etwas dagegen zu tun
das liegt aber nicht in unserer hand was
weil weil natürlich dazu fall gerade
beim wetter aber die tendenz zeichnet
sich ein bisschen heißt es ist klar dass
in dance ist klar also die die tendenzen
wenn sie die statistiken anschauen die
sind klar dass wir seit 50 jahren dass
es aufwärts geht und zwar zum teil
exponentiell ja aber aber in dieser
tendenz gibt es ein riesen rauschen dass
es schwierig macht die tendenz zu
erkennen für den bürger im alltag und
dieses rauschen das wir haben aufgrund
der zufälligkeit von wetterphänomenen
das macht das problem noch besonders
schwierig dann müssen wir paradoxerweise
irgendwie hoffen dass der diesjährige
sommer umso heißer wird damit ich bin
für alle auf diese straße gehen und für
die zukunft herr vielen herzlichen dank
für dieses
der informative und der handy-gespräche
danke ich danke ihnen auch ja und nach
ihnen danke fürs mitdenken nächsten
sonntag ist bereits ostern und barbara
bleisch spricht mit der regionalbischof
in petra bahr und fragt ob gott
eigentlich vom aussterben bedroht ist
und jetzt gleich sehen sie einen film
über arno stern und seine wundervolle
welt der mahnenden kinder bleiben sie
also dran und ein
[Musik]